ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show live from Los Angeles
California hey guys it's been a 'very
the producer we have a special treat for
you tonight it's the best of patreon vol
1 so I went through 6 of my favorite
episodes and found excerpts from them
and what we're gonna play for you is
just sort of the tip of the iceberg when
it comes to everything we have behind
that pay wall on the patreon if you want
to go find those episodes that I pulled
stuff from I will have links in the
description it's only $5 a month
patreon.com slash the Tim Dylan show
it's a way to get a bonus RSS feed that
me and Tim put stuff out on we have a
lot of great great great episodes on
there not even to mention we have a
hundred forty-five archives of old
episodes of the show with interviews
with CIA agents russ Baker Nick Bryant
there's tons of stuff with Tim and Ray
that's absolutely hysterical along with
a lot of other comedians on the patreon
bonus episodes now we're around 29 bonus
episodes so far that feature gown is
Papa's crista Stefano Jessa read and a
lot of other comedians mostly it's just
Tim doing solo or Tim and Ray so go
check out the patreon patreon comm slash
the Tim Dillon show so I'm now going to
play you six things I pulled from random
patreon episodes that I really liked
this next segment is from bonus episode
6 put it on the ham where Tim tells a
really funny story about growing up and
to lead into that story it's going to
start with Tim talking about the passing
of the late great Karl Ruiz you know we
all have those moments where you look
around and you go I gotta get out of
here whatever here is
you know you might be in a party you
might be in a bar you might be in a
relationship you might be at a job you
just look around you gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here
and I gotta try to figure out how I got
here how did they get here right and
where and how do I get somewhere else
and Carl was a [ __ ] character man he
was very funny as funny the most
comedians you know he was passionate
about food love would would review like
you know the popeyes chicken sandwich
he'd review like fast food he'd review
everything he loved working-class people
genuinely genuinely he didn't pretend to
yeah he loved the food that they ate he
loved the places they hung out
he loved the bars that they went to he
spent a lot of time in those places he
would go and get you know chip beef
sandwich upstate he'd go [ __ ] all
over the place and he genuinely loved
those types of people there's a lot of
people in my business that pretend to
like those people on the left and the
right yeah whether you're lean to left
to lean to the right
in entertainment as a lot of people
pretend to like working-class people
which I never have by the way thank you
isn't that nice I've never really
pretended yeah I've claimed to only be
interested in the super-rich and I've
been pretty consistent about that yeah
you know you got integrity I mean I've
been pretty you know it's like you see
me outside of a factory and like don't
close it what no I listen I like working
things but I love characters and I won't
even have health insurance and stuff
like that but I mean the people that
interest me are rich people I've been
very honest about that because I think
they're doing a lot of [ __ ] up wild
[ __ ] these are those are the people that
I not to say that like you know I'm
working class all my friends are working
class everyone I grew up with and I know
his working class so it's not like those
are the fun or people those that people
want to perform comedy for you know what
Carl literally loved those people met
Carl really cared about people he cared
about the guys that were line cooks he
cared about the guys that he stood next
to in the kitchen he gave a [ __ ] about
all of those people and it's just so
funny because he didn't advertise it in
the way that people do in this business
when they're like I love the working
class like he never said they just love
the working place selfies with janitors
yeah he just cared about people yeah
mani can he care and he went to the
places they hung out and he loved you
know the food and he understood it and
he was like [ __ ] he understood
people's relationship with food and that
some of it was destructive some of it
was you know hehe guising to be fully
great I mean I I since I was a kid I've
loved restaurants and food and the whole
culture of it and a lot of it mirrors
the culture of drugs or an access or you
know anything
and there's rituals there's you know all
that stuff involved in eating and in
taking drugs and use drugs and drinking
and sax or whatever it is and Carl kind
of understood maybe better than so many
other people the role that food played
especially in the lives of people who
didn't have a lot and this was a fun
thing for them to do the food and drink
was actually a fun thing to do was kind
of this escape it was a release it was a
place where even if they didn't have a
lot of money they could save some money
to go to a nice restaurant and it's an
indulgence and they enjoyed it they
could afford that they could never
afford a Maserati it could never afford
a house in the hills of LA they could
never afford a mansion you know wherever
and wherever but they were able to go
out and eat something good and I I was
always a guy who the only things I ever
did with money was go out and eat so
Carl got that he I think he understood
that food was important to people
especially working-class people people
that didn't have enough you know and he
you know he had this whole thing rui-zi
it was hashtag reason which was rui-zi I
mean I think a few days before he died a
week before he died he was like on the
Long Island Rail Road heading out to
Long Island and he tweeted will somebody
meet me with a pack of cigarettes and
and and some white cloth something at
the train station and immediately it
happen
you know like a guy was waiting for him
as soon as he got off the train but
that's what Carl would do there were no
strangers in you know and I'll talk
about this a little bit on the on the
regular episode not not as long but like
that guy didn't they weren't it they
would they were Frank like it sounds
cliche and stupid like oh there are
people that are that guy that we know
strangers they were just friends he
hadn't met yet but that guy made friends
with people you know he just wanted to
hang out he wanted to drink he wanted to
eat he wanted to laugh that's all he
wanted to do he didn't want to hurt
anybody
he didn't want to be powerful he wanted
he didn't want to Bews people he didn't
want to Lord power over everybody he
genuinely was passionate about cooking
about laughing and you know that's a
[ __ ] great example of somebody who
lives really lives who they are like you
know but it sucks because I would have
rather dim be around for a lot longer
you know which is why I think you do
have to moderate that dude you can't go
as hard all the time as you want to go
there's you know and I'm not you know
he's a very successful guy he's very
talented guy you know and he could up
you know it's very sad that he wasn't
around for as long as he could have been
you know and I don't know the
circumstances of his death but I just do
know that you know he was rui-zi
you know he went out he drank he ate he
laughed he had fun with people you know
and that's a shitty thing you know but I
mean that's all I can do is basically
say to myself like I want to be around
for a while you know and whatever that
means by someone I have fun and I still
want to be the type of guy that he was I
think you have to work harder at being
fun like if you if you say to yourself
I'm gonna get rid of the booze I'm gonna
get rid of it I'm not gonna be the guy
that just eats ridiculous [ __ ]
uh but I'm I still want to be fun like I
still want people to like me I still
want to be funny and I still want to
like be the life of the party to an
extent like
that might be a little harder but I
think it's you got to do it like I still
won't have a personality you know but I
don't want it to kill me
and so many dudes out there just kills
him we know guys not measuring their
names we know guys you look at them you
know you're being killed yeah you know
who you are is killing it mm-hmm you
know and and I just fall into that trap
dude of like not seeing a way out and
not going well I've only been this how
am I gonna be something else you know
you know I mean it's like it's tricky
you know I mean that being said put
Greta Thun Berg in jail put her in jail
throw away the key
what did Trump say about her because
happy girl happy girl excited for a
bright future yeah I mean this is who
you're putting in a que like this is he
putting in the Roman Colosseum with
Trump the 16 year old Swedish girl
mm-hmm this is how deeply immoral our
society is the master troll psychopath
Donald Trump who has absolutely no
feelings who would feed his own kids to
a [ __ ] tiger if you needed to yeah
and we're putting in the Roman Colosseum
with him we're putting a 16 year old
Swedish girl autistic Swedish girl and
that's that's what we're gonna do
seems like not the move you know seems a
little ridiculous but yeah I'm bummed
man I was gonna fly bad or no if they do
in a memorial form or something but I
was gonna get I've gotta be in LA and
fortunately this thing about but you
know I mean this is what happens is any
good friend of yours died me me call it
wasn't like a insanely good friend but I
really did like him mmm what about any
but good friend of yours ever died no
I'm not yet known about you Ben yeah I
wish that for you both of you you know
we'll be probably the only some the only
somewhat the only somewhat successful
person either one of you have ever
really met everybody else is just a
complete loser
just go back to sitting on the porch
getting mad at people with 300 Twitter
followers it's ridiculous but it is a
[ __ ] it is a wake-up call man it's a
wake-up call it should be a wake-up call
where you're just like but he really did
understand that not that's what food is
dude food is a [ __ ] drug I mean
you're sitting in a fast food place you
open up this hot warm salty fatty sugar
you know and you you open it up and you
just go this is this is something nice
I've worked a hellish job it sucked and
I'm just gonna have this one thing that
tastes good I just want to have this one
[ __ ] thing right now that tastes good
you know so I could feel full and I can
go to bed and I don't have to think
about you know yeah I just want to
really it's such a small amount of time
to like that we we give for like food
it's just a nice taste for three four
minutes so you know I mean like it's
like that long of a of a thing to
indulge in but we just it's it's we love
it for a lot of people man it's the only
indulgence yeah you know you're not on
your boat yeah they're not on the boat :
this is nice they get a few minutes a
day at lunch now when they get out of
work you know yeah I almost never look
at food is like fuel I just want it I
just want something fun you know yeah I
mean that's that's that's a lot of us
man especially when I stopped drinking I
started getting really into like dessert
I never cared about dessert I always
wanted to leave the restaurant go to a
bar right I didn't care then you stopped
drinking you're like oh I'll have all
the desserts because I just want to eat
you know eat sugar now you know you got
to train yourself man and it's [ __ ]
sucks you know especially when you were
raised with the attitudes towards food I
was raised with which was raised by two
people that exemplified the group of
people the boomers who everything was
convenience and what was easy
and if it was easy to just get a pizza
from Pizza Hut or get fast food on the
way back like and and listen you know in
defense of them they had jobs they had
you know all right it is what it is they
[ __ ] you know but you know when
you're raised to it I was raised I mean
these are the rest like these are the
places that I ain't growing up okay did
I and I can remember them I can remember
all of them that I would eat like I
would consider somewhat frequently
McDonald's McDonald's is one of my
earliest memories for a lot of people
dude for a lot of people one of your
earliest memories is it you're eating
McDonald's yeah good and you like it and
then you ask your parents to go back
they got the play place and they're all
the characters are fun and you're in
McDonald's McDonald's when I was a kid
Boston Market when I was a kid I've
loved Boston Market Kentucky Fried
Chicken when I was a kid what the Boston
Market one day I used to come in after
dance class and I had this like and I
was like squeezed in this leotard and I
was like just like newly fat body
squeezed and like this purple and black
leotard that made me look try to look
like a hip-hop DJ uh-huh and I was
standing there and I used to sneak if
you get two sides when you got your
chair hey am I using it am and I would
sneak a third side on which was cinnamon
apples but the way I snuck it on as I'd
say put it on the ham and then the woman
would put it on the ham move it off I
actually put it on the ham then I would
get the beans and the mac and cheese but
I said hey put the apples on a half the
way this is a way that you would get a
third side yeah in Boston Market so I
remember I remember standing there and I
was in with my you know just dressed
like a hip-hop DJ with my midriff my
little gut sticking out of my midriff
and there was a new woman there and she
like barely spoke English and I said I
want to see him in a pose but put it on
the ham and she
and she put it in one of the things and
I I just I just I'd had a very grueling
day at dance where I'd fallen a bunch of
times so I was like almost bursting into
tears and I just started screaming put
it on the ham what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
put it on the ham and the two african
guys in back of her that were carving
the chicken started chanting put it on
dom bulges and aha and I was like
screaming and crying and then this lady
started crying she cuz she didn't know
what was happening and then the woman
who is a manager always like a
middle-aged white woman with glasses she
came over and I explained to her and she
was well usually we would charge extra
for that but you know we'll do it we'll
just put some cinnamon apples on the ham
it's not a big deal and I was like thank
you but now no matter what I do like
whether it's a Netflix special I always
stand before I go onstage whether it's
Comedy Central whether it's you know
rogue but it's something important I
just I I always say put it on the ham
[ __ ]
before I do I'm kidding I don't but this
next excerpt is from bonus episode 7
Beverly Hills Cop where me and Tim were
just driving around in my toyota up
through the hills of Beverly Hills
making our way to North Beverly Park and
Tim is just talking about dark money and
epstein and he's sort of getting back
into the role of being a tour guide
which I really love this is a really
long episode this is a 20-minute part
from it I found super fascinating this
is really really wealthy a lot of these
houses they start around five million
and then they climb pretty quickly into
the 20s and 30s you know and then even
you know there are estates in Beverly
Hills that are 75 million 80 million 100
million and I think there's a house for
the market in LA and I think it's
perfectly Hills for a hundred and
seventy five million and you know the
person who owns that is guidance
counselor and she just believed in her
kids and that's how she made that kind
of money you know no no
people ask about this kind of money
they're like where does this kind of
money come from does it come from
lawyers and doctors and the professional
class account and stuff like that not
really this isn't really even CEOs or
companies unless they're large major
multinationals the reality here is the
majority of people that are not in the
entertainment business are in finance or
they're in tech or they're in the
extraction of natural resources they
work at an energy company or they work
in some you know I mean most of the war
money is in and around Maryland in
Virginia and DC which is why the you
know the top 10 wealthiest counties I
think eight of them are right there but
some of those [ __ ] live out here
chill don't kid yourself some of these
[ __ ] live right out here but that's
what people are doing to make that kind
of money there's not too many lawyers up
here with 30 or 40 million dollar houses
unless they're in the top you know 0.001
percent of all lawyers you know so the
professional class of people did it kind
of most people are familiar with don't
live up here a lot of this is foreign
money it's inherited money it's
descendants of royalty tack on a very
high level CEOs of companies that are
major corporations major multinationals
or you have people that have private
companies that you've never heard of
that make doodles of money also you
might potentially have obviously actors
actresses sports people and he's an
interesting one been the black house
nothing satanic going on there they
answer the door every day they're like
I'll Satan's all hello we just passed a
solid black house in Beverly Hills
nothing Goods happening in that basement
folks tell you that much and as you walk
you're obviously see their people
polishing cars and some of these houses
are actually not impressive right here
these are some not impressed you know
some of them are nice but we're heading
up into an area that's completely gated
where we will be asked to leave and turn
around
because these people do not want people
like me we were driving right now and
Benz what is this it's an Avalon it
looks like an uber that's a nice
it's relatively new how old is it 2008
it's not new at all I'm disgusted I'm in
this car now that I found that out and
I'm sitting in the front seat with a
microphone and we're we're heading up
and the houses starting a little bigger
they were bigger on the as you go up the
hill the houses get a little smaller
they're bigger down by the base and then
they're big once you get to the top of
the hill but as you go up the hill the
houses are not nearly as impressive I
imagine these people are like the middle
class they make five to ten million a
year you know which was the middle class
I don't think they make much less than
five a year maybe they do maybe some of
these people do make less than five
million dollars a year but once you get
up into two go [ __ ] your mother money
section these are people who are making
you know I remember I told people that
you know David Tepper who's a hedge fund
manager he bought all the stocks
financials he bought all those up with
his hedge fund when they cratered in
2007 he sold them or but in 2008
whatever he sold him in 2013 his hedge
fund made 7.5 billion his personal
income that year was 3.5 billion there
our hedge fund guys had make eight
hundred million a year three hundred
million a year you know what I mean and
I think that's what people don't realize
you feel in your ears when you go up the
hill don't you Ben so I mean the amount
of money that is made I think is
unfathomable Chris Rock said once you
guys if people knew how rich people were
there'd be a riot which is true like the
amount of money when you get up here is
crazy and then you'd have to look up
these people you'd have to google these
people how did they make this kind of
[ __ ] money and I got on this kick
when I was a tour guide in New York City
and I'd show people a building I would
look at the average price of the
building I mean the average price of the
apartment in the building it would be
like 20 million dollars I'd be like well
what the [ __ ] do these people do who are
they and then you'd learn really crazy
[ __ ] like there was this woman Louise
crane who lived in one of these
buildings I think it was 834 8th 25th
Avenue she lived she her family sold the
paper to the mint that our money was
printed on that our currency was printed
on this [ __ ] own money so now we are
here at the top of the hill we're at
Beverly Park the cave houses let's do
Souths with these are the gate houses to
get up in a Beverly Park this is the
most expensive section of the country
other than of course Sagaponack in the
Hamptons perhaps you've heard of it New
York shout out to New York and people
that also hate me they're people that
want nothing to do but I have that
hometown pride even though those people
would kill me so now we're gonna have to
turn around Benjamin we go right to the
gatehouse Benjamin see the gates we're
right up here at the gatehouse look at
the view Benjamin look at all the houses
Ben grew up in Texas and a bag of Fritos
and it's very nice from to see this it's
very inspiring for him because he grew
up in a house where they just ate bloody
meat and they were like Jesus Saves
if Jesus came to you Durkin off he gonna
kill you and Ben was like oh I'm sorry
mother he was British I'm sorry mother
you see some of the houses Ben you see
the bat is the Beverly Park over there
that's North Beverly Park let's go up to
the gatehouse up here up here right at
the understand you see Joe and the
reality is the idea that I'm not
welcomed into these communities is
frankly disgusting it's frankly
disgusting because I've done nothing but
entertain for free so Rolls Royce
Phantom Bentley's now it's getting
banana now it's getting bananas it's
getting stupid now stupid this is stupid
money so now we're getting into some
houses they're like [ __ ] you Benjamin
you got to go back down that Street cuz
that was to the gatehouse we got to go
to the gatehouse we got to go to the
gate make them tell us no Benjamin don't
don't be poor you rich [ __ ] seeing that
the Antwoord saw him rich [ __ ] I'm a
rich [ __ ] but that's the thing about
this type of money it's actually
fascinating to start looking up we're
gonna do more of that [ __ ] on the
patreon where we'll actually talk about
some of these people so it is kind of
fascinating and interesting how much
money and how much power certain people
have which why I think a guy like
Sanders would be good to shake the tree
I don't know how much shaking the tree
would matter and I think if Bernie shook
the tree it might land on him you know a
lot of people shake the tree so now it's
not a through Street but that's okay
violators will be prosecuted trespassing
doesn't matter Benjamin keep going have
balls now we are in the most exclusive
area in the country right now folks
North Beverly Park
keep going bad don't be a [ __ ] here's
the game the gate stops us I thought
we're gonna get in Ben now just make the
uee I thought we were gonna get in gated
community but look at the house right
behind the gate here
I mean Disney World you see it up in the
tree you can barely say it you can't say
it yeah it's wild did I mean it's wild
they do not let you in here
and that's okay but you could see them
over there the houses the homes these
are massive estates folks these are
massive and you know I'm be I've been
kept out of these communities I've been
denied
I've been literally [ __ ] on my whole
life people just open they open my mouth
and they [ __ ] directly into my mouth and
I have to swallow that [ __ ] for many
many years and all I all I've tried to
do is go into wealthy areas now what I
will do and then I'll tell you this I
will walk around in wealthy areas
without case I get a cup of coffee and I
and I will like sweatpants to look like
I just woke up and I'll just walk around
these areas like Hancock Park that are
rich that don't have gates I guarantee
there are areas that will have gates in
California in three years because of me
the residents will get together and go
get that fat [ __ ] out of here we're
putting up a game guaranteed folks
guaran-fucking-tee it's a beautiful fall
day here if I could do it all over again
I'd just be rich as [ __ ] and I'd kill
people I wish I was [ __ ] just crazy
rich but instead I'm a creative genius
[ __ ] now we're we're in a coldest
it's a dead end there are several
Mexicans and they're all looking at me
and benches they know that we're not the
type of white that belongs here a lot of
construction going on here Alyssa these
areas are over built New York City's
over built there's too much high-end
[ __ ] on the market there's not enough
foreign money to pump into these markets
you will see you know values decline to
a degree in these areas because you know
especially once we head into the
recession but you've already see wealthy
people are starting to hoard cash
because they know what's coming they
know before us what's gonna happen
because they make it happen through the
gray so they're already starting to
hoard money and not buy these homes we
got to remember one of the real reasons
that New York City real estate market
did not suffer during the financial
crisis is that domestic money was
replaced by foreign money and foreign
people came over to America and they
wanted to move their money out of Russia
and China and the United Arab Emirates
and Brazil and India and they wanted to
buy homes in New York and London and
also Los Angeles to a degree to a lesser
degree and you know London is a great
financial capital that's halfway between
New York and Asia so London is number
one
London is number one with foreign money
sixty to seventy percent of all new
construction in London is is it it was
at one time and I'm sure it still hovers
around that percentage now going to
people that do not live in Britain they
are not you know they might have
citizenship but the majority is a lot of
them are foreign nationals without
citizenship and it's not their primary
residence and they're buying up
snatching up lots of real estate their
New York is second there's a lot of
people buying in New York you get rid
great return on your investment in a
city like New York in London you could
let it sit vacant and it'll just
appreciate in value if you buy an
apartment you could also rent it out and
you get a lot of money and none of these
people are buying it under their own
name they're buying it under the name of
a
shell Corp which is a corporation that
is set up really primarily to invest in
real estate also private companies but a
lot of times it's real estate and what
people why do people use a shell Corp so
that they are not on the hook for taxes
that they can kind of launder money in
these cities through real estate and the
extent to which real estate it's used
for money laundering is pretty well
known but it's only intensified over the
last decade slow down a little bit now
but you want to talk about you know how
crazy it was going you know right after
the financial crisis people came over
here and just started buying buying
buying and that's where you get into
like things like the Panama papers and
the person that released the Panama
papers is now dead I forget how probably
a bad called and the Panama papers were
an explanation of this of this other
financial system that wealthy people had
set up for themselves where they put
their money offshore and you know the
New York Times to their credit actually
read a great article that was pretty
complicated that very few people read
that was about how people especially
wealthy people route their money through
companies that don't exist so that they
can pay corporate tax rates and these
companies don't exist and they have you
know they have addresses but there's
there's no employees and there's no
offices and there's no they they just
exist simply to kind of clear money
they're like a clearinghouse of money
I'll post some of these articles on the
patreon because I would imagine some of
the people that are listening to this
are a little smarter than the regular
people we got we're over a hundred
thousand downloads on the episode now so
there's a lot of different kinds of
people listening to show they're in all
kinds of different [ __ ] you people are
probably a little bit smarter now not
all of you not all of you I will let
rain that in let's roll that back
there's many people here that are not
but there are a few people that want to
read some of these articles so we will
post them it's a great article it's a
dense article it's a long article but
you start to look at what what a
separate financial system looks like
because it's really completely separate
four people at a certain net worth and I
think it a certain net worth you just
start to spend time with people that
just kind of piss in your ear I'm not
even talking about people that are make
it five million a year I'm talking about
serious money intergenerational wealth
where where this is just the way things
are done and and there's all kinds of
people that make money showing you how
to shield yourself from taxes and
accountability and and and guys like I
forget his name I think it's a neat
Agarwal Agarwal his last name I forget
his first name who bought an apartment
of the Time Warner Center
this is a very controversial mining
magnate who like poison to River and
Zambia and he so what you have you see
two girls there at stand in front of a
pink house with pink hair
is that--do Jacquet we're hunting for
dosha cat we want to find the cat
what do you think she isn't jollibee but
what the whole thing is I want to flesh
out some of this stuff because this is
by the way this is the key to Epstein
this is the key taps team and I want you
to start thinking about this in a more
broader context than just pedophiles and
Satanism and human sacrifice which by
the way all probably happening why did
you stay there benjamin been stayed
oh that's we're which isin used to live
Ben is one of the slaves for the Eisen
family and was for many years good for
him this is what I want you to think of
it I've seen in a more broad context of
the human trafficking obviously
paedophile blackmail obviously but what
Epstein did I think and from from people
that are that from when you where boy I
spoke to who's done a lot of great work
on it and from a lot of people that I
spoke to both on and off the record they
believe Jeffries main other than the
blackmail and all of that stuff they
believe one of his main functions was
washing dirty money laundering money
okay um it wasn't only the type of money
that would be earned from human
trafficking but you're looking at
narco-terrorism drugs you're looking at
god only knows the kind of corporate
malfeasance he was tasked with making go
away or cleaning up in the financial
system finding places to put the money
finding places for the money to go you
got to remember Lex west or less wax
know who is Jeffery Epstein's mentor and
good friend and gave him his mansion in
New York City and gave him les Wexner
was questioned his attorney or
accountant I think his accountant was
going to testify about offshoring
profits who's gonna testify about
offshoring money and he was shot in the
face before he's able to do that he was
killed in broad daylight in a mafia
style head so this issue cuts right to
the core of what we're talking about so
it's like we're driving around Beverly
Hills and you're like well how does that
connect to everything well it connects
to everything actually it is everything
it actually is the core of everything
because there isn't one
only one illicit stream of money there
are many illicit streams of money that
are not accounted for that are not taxed
the CIA uses illicit money black-budget
all the time because they do things that
they don't want to sorry Bryan Callen
they do things that they don't want the
Senate Intelligence Committee to know
about that's why they bugged the Senate
Intelligence Committee that's why
they've admitted to spying on the Senate
Intelligence Committee because they
don't want the Senate Intelligence
Committee to know what they're doing so
they want to know what the Senate
Intelligence Committee knows because
they do underground activities the CIA
so when you talk about the illicit
streams of money that guys like Jeffrey
Epstein direct and manage and you look
at the amount of people not all of the
pedophiles some of them just regular
crooks to regular old crooks and
so then it gets very messy right so now
you took a bit Epstein right so let's we
talk about like well what happens if
Jeffrey goes in and sinks is it just
people that have been to his island that
go down or does he hold the key to a lot
of nefarious activities and a lot of
bold-faced names and a lot of powerful
people that are beyond the scope of even
that island you know what I mean and I
think the reason that you can't let
Jeffrey sing obviously
you can't let him talk about politicians
diddling children on an island that is
no good that is a problem but the other
reason is because I don't think the
press can truly get a whiff of how
insanely corrupt the financial system is
how many people are benefiting from it
and the role of guys like Jeffrey
Epstein or kind of these cowboys that
are somewhat rootless he blows around
the globe he's friends with everybody's
friends with Mohammed bin Salman in
Saudi Arabia he's friends with political
leaders in the United States and yes a
lot of it is probably the you know
pedophilia and stuff like that be gonna
realize it's pretty nobody's a pedophile
that's also refute like nobody's a
pedophile but doesn't cheat on their
taxes is what I mean like if you're
doing that you're probably open to drugs
and cheating in any way that you can you
know and illegal arms dealing that's why
he's friends with kugali and you know
kakashi this huge arms dealer Epstein
was good friends with two so there's
this whole underground economy where you
have illicit streams of money you have
capital that needs to find a home and
you have guys like Jeffrey Epstein so as
much as it is about this island and it
is about the appetites of the wealthy
enough these people are getting out of
control because now we're back down in
the area where you have you know some of
the poor here and you know I mean poor B
meaning BMWs like three and five series
no good very aggressive
they're striving to climber's they're
trying to get to the top of the hill and
they're there in a rush people at the
top of the hill aren't even a rush
they're not even home they don't even
exist go to a rich area you never see
the people cuz they they maintain
multiple properties there's somewhere
else here's a couple of just nice
autistic brothers walking around countin
blades of grass God loved him jumping -
bonus episode 26 steyr Stan in this
segment
Tim talks about the healthcare industry
and what we'd have to do to actually get
people to be healthy in this country
this is why I'm literally this is me now
I'm gonna run I'm gonna run Ben and I
want you to ask me questions that you
hear people asking I'm gonna give you my
real answers I'm on the stage I'm I'm
running Tim Dylan is now running for the
Presidency of America I want you to ask
me real questions okay Tim Dylan what is
your proposal for our immigration policy
that we have right now in America
here's a reality of the situation folks
there's a lot of boomers that are
retiring somebody's gonna need to wipe
their ass we're gonna shove them into
assisted living facilities hopefully
immediately hopefully by force we're
gonna need people to go in there drug
these boomers up they're gonna be
drooling and [ __ ] all over the place
and we're gonna need somebody to do it I
don't really want to do it many of my
lazy friends are probably not going to
do it either so we need some immigrants
to just chain my parents and your
parents to their beds so that they can
piss and [ __ ] themselves until they die
now that being said we can't let
everybody in because that would break
the economy so what we're gonna have to
do is we're gonna bring immigrants in
that have the skillset to chain my aunt
Kathleen to a chair and an assisted
living facility and be her we're gonna
give them on Facebook we give them on
Facebook and let them scream into the
void so we need some immigrants we don't
we but we can't have everybody next
question what is your plan with with
health care in America
two real ongoing issue a lot of people
weren't covered there in medical debt
how do you seek to rectify this whole
situation here's what we're gonna do
with health care here's what we're gonna
do with health care we're going to
here's what you really have to do by the
way yeah this is what people don't want
to hear you're gonna have to like outlaw
Denny's and IHOP and Carl's jr. you're
gonna have to put the military around
calls junior numb doesn't up like
actually dead serious now you're gonna
have to put people with guns outside of
Popeyes and calls Junior you're gonna
have to outlaw like buffets you're gonna
have to outlaw breakfast cereals that
literally deliver more sugar to the
brain of a child than they should have
in their entire existence in a sitting
um like we could give you free
healthcare folks and you should get it
health care should be a right but I mean
if we don't you know we're gonna have to
just go in there and we're gonna have to
tell people that they have to stop with
the food and the booze I mean I don't
know that anybody wants to hear this
you're gonna have to get like a you're
gonna have to get like a card where you
get to go out to eat you get to go out
to eat like it's we're gonna have to run
the country like Weight Watchers except
it's gonna have to be enforced by the
prison system like if you go over your
points we're gonna have to put you in
jail like if you if you go over your
points and Weight Watchers we're gonna
have to have a Stasi like police force
drag you out of your house and throw you
in prison because all the health care in
the world is not gonna work when Denny's
is slinging salted caramel banana cream
french toast to 400-pound people in San
Antonio it's just not gonna work
literally every theme restaurant in the
country is trying to kill everyone that
lives here and literally every single I
mean the menu would get get the menu get
up the menu at Denny's just get up the
menu
deniz like this is the real nobody will
do this by the way onstage like nobody
will go let's take a look I want that
candidate who goes yeah oh great
yeah health care it's that so bad but
let's look at the menu at America's
diner quote their words America's diner
let's see what we have you want to see
featured items first um let's go to
fluffy pancakes how we start our day
this is how America starts our dad this
is how we start the day please read us
some of the offerings Benjamin classic
tres leches pancakes tres leches
pancakes cinnamon roll pancake breakfast
salted caramel and banana cream pancake
breakfasts that doesn't even sound good
by the way go-to salted caramel banana
cream pancake breakfast let's view the
item now buttermilk pancakes now read
read this by the way in Europe like this
would be illegal and people would be
sent to jail if they would firebomb a
restaurant to try to serve this by the
way it's almost hilarious discussing
health care and leaving out all of this
right let's read the description of the
item buttermilk pancakes cooked with
shortbread pieces and topped with
vanilla cream banana and even more
shortbread pieces by the way that is
literally their quote serve with a
picture of warm serve the pitcher of
warm salted caramel for drizzling serve
with two eggs two eggs two eggs hash
browns plus two bacon strips or two
sausage links and I bet you could turn
that or into an and nutritional facts
how many calories Benjamin fourteen
hundred and thirty calories okay let's
look at something else let's look at
something else let's go to the double
berry banana pancake breakfast because
this looks good as [ __ ] buttermilk
pancakes cooked with blueberries atop
with fresh seasonal berries bananas and
whipped cream served with two eggs hash
browns two bacon strips okay this is
their healthy meal it's only a thousand
calories how much was the cinnamon roll
breakfast o'clock in a nap
1810 1810 let's see what in 1810
calories on buttermilk pancakes cook
with cinnamon crumb topping and top
serve with a picture of warm cream
cheese
cheese icing for drizzling plus 2x
resume guys what health care let's be
honest what health care program is going
to compete with America's diner 1800
cinnamon roll pancake everybody in this
country should be forced to smoke
cigarettes in a health initiative right
now there should be a health initiative
called light up if it if it even saves
your appetite off for a minute now go to
the grand slam which Benjamin find the
ps2 resistance the Grand Slam become the
Grand Slam which by the way this is a
bigger threat to our country than
terrorism has ever been has ever been
let's find the Grand Slam which the
Grand Slam which is my favorite so it
might not be in super sandwiches it's
not there oh it's not a super sandwiches
no maybe featured items classic
breakfast faves go to classic breakfast
faves right there yeah I think we're
gonna I think we're getting to the yep
now go to the grand slam which what do
we got here
11 of 50 calories listen to this folks
listen to this by the way it looks like
someone vomited on bread scrambled eggs
this is my favorite scrambled eggs
sausage bacon ham American cheese on
potato bread grilled with a maple spice
spread served with hash browns so here's
the thing with health care I mean folks
well what are we doing like Denny's I
hop go to Carl's jr. Google Carl's jr.
you want to get a health care like it
it's one thing it's an immoral health
care system but I mean I hate to say it
but we're
need to put the military outside of
Carl's jr. let's see the different
burger options because I think one of
them has five four or five patties on it
okay all right see sorry it's a little
we have a little traffic here we're
sitting out on the the new porch let's
look at the Western bacon cheeseburger
what are we looking at on the Western
bacon burger
did they give you calorie counts no this
the thing isn't loading on their website
here that's convenient
this rep website is run by acronym that
brought you shadow oh here I got it now
you have to add the item okay but go
find the one that has five patties or
whatever it is the big Carl or they're
really it's the really big goat of a
really big Carl how many patties on the
really big car this one's got three
three patties on the really big Carl let
me add it to my cart add the really big
Carl to the car okay this is great how
do you add it again I this one is not
letting me at it here's what I think
people need to realize here it's like
people talk about like the weapons
industry and the pharmaceutical industry
but the food industry like fast food and
fast casual food now many people know
about me that I called Tim you're fat
fine Steakhouse fat that's still bad
still bad I'm not called jr. fat like I
didn't get fat it calls Junior I got fat
if you come to my live show you'll will
do we talk about Wendy's you talk about
the hot but I mean this is the problem
with health care it's like this is and
dude forget show duh forget that I don't
drink so I've never drank anything with
bubbles I just don't like carbonation
but think about the amount of people
that are eating this food day in and day
out you know it's just it's kind of a
nightmare and I'm a freedom guy I want
everyone to have freedom
but at what point do you say and for all
on it if we're all on a program right
like if we're all on a healthcare
program a public option at what point do
you say like you can't go out and have a
big Karl every day at lunch you can't
have a big Karl should there be a card
that you go to use and they got nob
you've had two big Karl's you've already
had two big car and a really big car oh
yeah you've had a really big car
yesterday you had a really big Karl
today you came in here to have a big car
like you it's you can't do it you can't
eat tres leches pancakes
in the morning you know go to the
unhealthiest items in America I mean the
Cheesecake Factory got a bunch I mean we
won't do the whole episode talking about
this but like there is just this idea
that personal responsibility is
completely vanished from like anything
and that nobody's responsible for
anything
yeah let's read some of these okay 15
highest calorie restaurant meals Buffalo
Wild Wings we got at 15 the cheese curd
bacon burger dude that's vomit-inducing
Jesus dude cheese curds are disgusting
I'm sorry if you're from that frozen
tundra of Wisconsin with all those [ __ ]
but they're disgusting and they put it
deep fried cheese curds on top of a
bacon cheeseburger 2,000 calories I mean
dude it's not even good I love Outback
Steakhouse herb-roasted prime rib is
next look at that big fat slab my mother
loves that 2,400 cows i hot cheese
burger omelet with pancakes I mean if
you go to another country and you showed
them this food literally if you sat down
with someone in Belgium if someone
started to make this food like this is
where age is getting fact is they're now
getting our fast food and you're seeing
like fat Asians for the first time but
like other European countries every
about these socialist countries like
Denmark and Norway here's what they're
not doing they're not slinging
cheeseburger omelets and tres leches
pancakes to the population by the way
for a very like low price this is not
expensive no you can go in and kill
yourself from $9 Shake Shack keep going
down listen to the Sonics pineapple
upside-down master blast shake I'm by
the way gross vanilla ice cream
pineapple salted caramel and pie crust
pieces this is the thing folks it's this
is not even good it doesn't taste good
like that's what I think people and I
guess people just so upset
and they don't realize that literally
you're ingesting poison that isn't even
enjoyable it's a literal drug and Dave &
Buster's carnivore Pizza dia it doesn't
it sounds like an attack it doesn't even
sound like food 2000 calories a giant
quesadilla stuff with Manchego chatter
cheese pepperoni sausage smother no more
cheese pepperoni sausage me and Ben were
in Vegas and we walked past a heart
attack grill which is where people die
while eating there and they're proud of
it and you're looking at people sitting
in this place eating butter fat
milkshakes and like six patty burgers
and it's like it's become as big of a
problem as the opioid crisis now it's
not as expensive as heroin so no one's
killing you no one's stabbing you in the
street to go get tres leches pancakes
but you remember what Michelle oh my
Christine funny comic out of New York
had a great joke about this he's like
remember when Michelle Obama's like we
should all eat salads and then one fat
white woman was like but I feel
beautiful the way I am and we're like
all right yeah [ __ ] the salad initiative
lena Dunham's like no but I'm booty-ful
everyone's like okay you're right
everyone gets so mad that Michelle Obama
was trying to feed kids broccoli
remember that people like she's a
communist she's trying to make these key
because she just didn't want like people
eating whoppers for lunch bonus episode
27 live from Toronto this was recorded
last week Tim and the great Raymond
Kampf performed the podcast live I hope
you enjoyed this segment I mean would
you prefer royalty to what we have in
America now I mean what do we what would
you even call what we have
it's like rape boil tea or something
yeah I mean what we have now is just
cottage close to professional wrestling
yeah as it's ever been
I mean it's it's pretty just people
hitting each other with chairs up there
right I mean how great with me though
it's like we had to like literally put a
crown on Trump yeah I mean that's yeah
that would be fun what people don't get
us it's like it is the ruling classes
just losing power yeah and it is wild to
watch like they don't know what that you
Michael Bloomberg's trying to buy the
electors they don't know what to do
anymore
there's you're spending all this money
they don't know what to do it's there's
nothing to do I don't know what people
think is gonna like this is [ __ ] over
all right Chinese are taking over like
and like white man can not that [ __ ] I'm
just saying we've been scamming
everything for 200 years now it's done
you had it we had a run we had a good
run we had a nice run balance the books
it's like like I had a kid last night in
the show
he's like I'm majoring in social work
I'm like what are you you're gonna help
what are you doing with that like Social
Work where social putting people to mass
graves yeah I don't even know what it is
yeah it's not it's some kid getting
burned with cigarettes and you walk in
or we would just mean you would make it
so much worse the kid with my parents
hit me we're like 911 didn't even happen
you're whining about your parents
homeless heroin addict me like let's do
your taxes we're just all like poisoned
yeah cuz that is what social work is
it's like some junkie
like let's do a questionnaires
yeah good at let's do a questionnaire
what would you like when they have to
sit down and be like what do you want to
accomplish in this program really is she
right now would you like to accomplish
in this program sir
it's you know listen you know we we we
kid but you know God love everyone it's
a real problem there it's a real problem
Trump will probably win again you know
I'd imagine he would but Bernie Sanders
as a messianic thing going on and he's
good we like I don't think we'll get
anything done but that is what it is
like ideal it's what it is I mean switch
what where we live I don't understand
about the left is that you have it's
like there's Justin of whatever you
wanna call it the deeps whatever the
[ __ ] you call you loominatee they star
wars whenever the [ __ ] they feel like it
and you're trying to give away your
assault rifles right like what I
understand like resist on Twitter yeah
resist wrote Bernie it's like they got
who are you resisting with a [ __ ]
tweet or [ __ ] like yeah shoot people
right that's what we're saying I gotta
[ __ ] dustpan will hit you with it
like no but the other problem is that
all the pro-gun knots to say they don't
want to give up their guns cuz they're
like well it's if the government gets
too radical it's like it's too radical
now you're gonna shoot anyone start now
this is an entertainment show all shows
entertainment it's an entertaining show
it's entertainment it's not the only
real home defense
I think shouldn't be able to have a gun
for home defense I want you to be home
invaded and be cocked in a weird
scenario I don't care about that but I
do I do like the idea of like
overthrowing a government I think least
in America I mean the way you guys feel
about it but like that's how we were
raised nobody's gonna do that in America
except what's to fact exactly and the
only people who are doing it or like
defending racist statues right we like
militia
yeah the only thing they care about is
race and stature like you can [ __ ] our
kids but don't touch that robert e lee
statue
don't you dare that's our heritage
that's our goddamn history bill just
Barcia for like health care yeah they
would love them keep the guns it's so
true they never bring the guns out for
anything good yeah they're never like
clean up the planet with the guns they
never marched around with ak-47s Beyonce
a Grammy yeah she deserves it
what about the state of popular culture
and music I mean it's you were making
electronic music now many people don't
know this oh yeah I mean I dabble with
it I'm not you know it reminds me when
Diana died I was listening to techno
music on our radio bridges is dead the
princess here did you see yourself
becoming a DJ like Skrillex
I need to find maybe I mean the mouse
head Armin van Buuren I don't know these
people
Steve Aoki that dia you know the guy who
looks like a wizard I feel like I have
this vision of me like DJ and like I'm
dressed like a baby and how do I dress
how do you dress like a baby diaper and
just say you're in a diaper setup where
I'm like going through the crib I'm
spinning records I gotta be honest with
you this sounds amazing that's the thing
were that was happening in LA I'm not
even kidding if you walked in because la
showed knots and everyone's on so many
drugs that if they if they just saw you
in a big cage doing that people be like
yo that's baby calm that's DJ baby calm
like [ __ ] really man whoa
that guy
rad yeah with deadmau5 or whatever he's
rich
yeah he is rich so yeah I mean but the
state of music today I mean it just
seems like Gregorian chant for like
molesting children is like that's really
bad I wanna [ __ ] your dad and suck on
his tits use me like a toilet and then
like I'm your toilet
would you like Doge ikata look the OSHA
cat is just like the whole thing
crashing yeah it's like the simulation
just being like it's a good song that
juicy song do we have the ability here
to play music no no good phenomenal so
just out of curiosity I knew the answer
but I was gonna treat everyone to a song
but anyway I don't wanna be the old
fogey or whatever is that offensive
hello
don't worry he bites I'm a photographer
oh yeah that was that I'm scared I'm a
photographer you want me to show you how
to take a pretty face
I used to photograph weddings and bar
mitzvahs sweet 16 everything anything
you want
what mince words are great well you into
somatic all right
[Applause]
not mutually exclusive plenty of
self-hating Jews we found a self-hating
Jew and I love all because she doesn't
want to photograph apartments which no
one wants to run around a party and
photograph over a woman a Bar Mitzvah
why now yeah so anyway yeah I don't know
being like yeah what's her name again
Billy Eilish Billy Eilish she's no
Whitney Houston no wouldn't use it was
maybe the greatest singer of our time
right and you still end up getting a tub
you'll never not die in a tub that's the
point you go to Hollywood with all these
big ideas you die in a tub if you're
lucky we don't want like there's no
aspirational art anymore no we don't
want that we want like somebody that one
could do it I want like some amazing
night amazing so I want something decent
that randomly came out of a dying cancer
patients like notebook right and then
like you knew the guy that guy's also a
junkie I'm doing fine
yeah yeah that's what we no one wants to
be like I have to like spend ten years
like doing vocal lessons was like even
lizzo who's good but she's not great no
she's not like look market and Kerry
she's fat but like used to holding look
how proud of her bat by she is she's a
gem and like I don't care but like give
it like no-one's like what is this for
like what is this they're trying to keep
us as like cattle or something
like fat cattle yeah government wants me
to be fat yes
and like wants me that rotten teeth
that's why they [ __ ] made me drink
diet coke every day
Liz's gonna have a song soon my teeth
are rotten do you have dental samman I
want to perform my own operation on my -
why my teeth are [ __ ]
[Music]
what is a good thing to get that we
cannot get in America what no butene
here what'd you say
well here's the thing guys usually thing
with the poutine I'm not getting it at
McDonald's I mean that seems [ __ ] up
yeah Montreal yeah yeah that's that's
the other festival that's not in the
homeless shelter what is poutine like
french fries with cabbage french fries
cheese curds and like gravy it's pretty
good what else did you want to known for
a lot of Middle Eastern food right steak
they have a lot of steak houses here oh
you have a lot of steak here nice
well-done steak [ __ ] you yeah yeah
here's here's your charred beef and
don't and you'll put you jail if you say
the wrong thing here put me in jail for
[ __ ] being fat yeah well they should
I just want to be in a cage yeah he was
so excited I'm like you might go to jail
oh good he's like can we arrange this so
that I do go to jail like I don't want
to be using a toilet right the greatest
part of that sentence was but you're
like I don't want to be used like a
toilet but last but not least bonus
episode 8 it's a vibe this is one of my
favorite moments from any of the patreon
episodes where Tim talks about how easy
it is to be a recording artist and he's
just talking about Billy Eilish and this
guy he met in Houston I just love this
little chunk here enjoy a lot of people
from my high school graduate people seem
to be closer with people they met in
high school in college yes because you
go back I guess to this hometown and
stuff and many of the people that I am
that I was friendly with in high school
don't really talk to anymore they don't
reach out to me they're intimidated by
my fame and I remember the last time I
went back to Long Island I was trying to
get a bagel and I was inundated with
people that wanted pictures with me and
they wanted my autograph and many of
them are trying to [ __ ] me as I walked
in to get a bagel it was just very
annoying and they were just like hey can
I get a picture and [ __ ] you I was like
alright fine so I was on the big line I
was just [ __ ] them and they were
taking photos with me like selfies it
was just awkward but listen I get it
it's nice when someone you know ends up
being a famous star like me or Billy
I'll if Satan is my father in the night
he comes in my room and he gives me a
baby
save the world
and Jimmy found like that's great you're
such a talent I'd hug you but I'm
chained to my desk we don't want another
incident you know so all I'm saying
folks I don't know how to tell you how
to live just go to if you're a kid you
want to go away to school go away to
school have some fun out there enjoy
yourself you know go away go somewhere
different I've only lived in New York or
LA I've only lived in New York or Los
Angeles you know it's crazy to think
about and I'll probably never live
anywhere else you know I can't envision
baby when I'm older I'll move somewhere
else I think about that often but these
are the only two places I've lived it's
very unhealthy to very unhealthy
environments you know but they're really
the only two places that I can do what I
do you know which is inspire people all
over the world to really live I I got a
message other day from a child in India
who watches the show he's four and he
said Tim Tim Tim I don't know I can't do
an accent stop I just got it's not that
I'm against it I just can't even ice I'm
so bad at it why is it why is it it's
not I don't I'm not
disrespecting anyone if I do it but I
just they smoked a few cigarettes I
can't hello he says four year old wrote
me a letter he said Tim he said you know
things are not great here because I live
in a slum and he goes I think I you know
you know I think that it's very hard to
you know we don't really have Wi-Fi we
have one little computer here in the
whole small village and we all get
together and we watch the show all the
villagers will watch the podcast every
week and we they cancel their
subscriptions to guest in general many
of them after I left I didn't tell them
to do that but they did that they could
say what they would do he goes with
eating literal garbage here we're eating
garbage we're living in garbage we're
living living in in towns made of
garbage but when we watch your show and
you tell us that it's not gonna get
better we get it and we connect with it
now we understand and it makes sense to
us and we laugh because we laugh because
my brother was eaten by a tiger and he
said but watching you just kind of smoke
cigarettes on a porch in Los Angeles and
scream made me understand that even
though there probably is no God and we
live in an unending hellscape and
literal demons run this earth in this
reality reptilians from another
dimension suck joy out of people and
then they feed off negative energy and
they use it to create this paradigm that
we will live in and we can't get out of
it we don't know how the only way to do
it is high doses of psychedelic drugs
which I can't even afford
he goes even though that's all the case
and I know that I think this guy's for
spring even though that's the case he
because I still just get enjoyment from
watching you blow smoke into the Los
Angeles sky that's why I do it that's
why I do it I don't do it I don't do for
the money I'm gonna do for the fame I do
I do it for both I do it really for
those two things it's predominantly why
I do it those are the only two reasons I
do it literally those are literally the
only two reasons that anyone does it
anyone that says you don't do anything
for money or fame is a flyer they're
lying to your face I just do it for the
kids
yeah yeah okay but you know it is one of
my regrets if I gone to college what
kind of life would I've lived but I've
been a swimmer and good-looking not
funny then I would have really succeeded
in comedy I'd live in a small little
liberal arts ecology [ __ ] town and
I'd maybe I was still drank smoked a
little weed get in front of a room of
dumb kids and inspire those losers and
say I'm a teacher aren't I cool I'm the
cool teacher maybe I would have been the
cool teacher hey I'm the cool drama
teacher I'm the cool you know I was in
Houston with Christ room and there was a
couple of kids who are volunteering I
love cutting kids down it's one of my
favorite things I just just just looking
at him and going you're a fraud you know
I see that the baby sometimes I look at
him I go you're a fraud I'm but then
some babies are like [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
then I'm like interesting I respect you
there were these Street kids that were
they were volunteering at the theater
and I said what do you guys do they're
like we're in the theater program I said
oh that's good and I said so what
happens like after you graduate you move
to New York or LA and they go no
actually they go no actually uh Houston
got the third-largest arts community in
the country and I just went and I left
in their face and I went guys come on
don't be stupid as soon as I told that
to Bernie laughs I said and they said no
usually got the third largest liberal
arts community Brad the third largest
arts community and Bert laughed so hard
because you don't have it to go and
[ __ ] get kicked in the face there's
nothing wrong with that you know but
don't pretend that you're gonna make
some kind of career in [ __ ] Houston
Texas as a theater made can you stop cut
it out I just looked into my left right
in their goddamn faces and I said that's
it man I was a theatre group on my tour
bus one day when I was doing the tours
and they were like yeah some girl that
graduated she moved to New York City now
she thinks she's better than all of us
I'm like she is she is I went to a Long
Island a Holy Trinity High School that
we had one of the best theatre programs
we one of the first high schools and
what about dule Missouri I wasn't in the
theater groups I'm not a loser
I'm in the real theater okay okay tough
guy um and one of the one of the you
know that theater group produced the
best theater group on Lamont produced a
lot of lawyers because you're all full
of [ __ ] every one of those theater kids
should should have been made to play Jim
and made to do what I did run around a
track being chased by a fire-breathing
Dyke and look at penises while
pretending they weren't that would have
been a much better skill set for them to
[ __ ] have then [ __ ] this fake
[ __ ] theater [ __ ] thing then
nobody you should you should sign a
pledge if you get out of gym for four
years that you have to do theater for
ten years and ruin your life you should
be living in an inner in a [ __ ] you
know in a [ __ ] dirty apartment New
York with no hot water
going on auditions will you [ __ ]
clunky ass trying to dance around and
try to do it
Broadway's a hell if you get on Broadway
it's an absolute hell nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you we went to go see that
ferryman show so great nobody gives a
[ __ ] about those people spit on him
right in the street
I love the Shelf I ever saw one of those
people I would just spit right on him I
[Laughter]
saw that show three times
I liked it someone so good I I Phantom
of the Opera which sucks now it is just
it is so bad now so bad dude he used to
be so good there was a guy who was
clearly drunk yet no voice and he was
like one of the principles it was like
$600 she's like so expensive and the
guys like the guy was singing he's like
hi tattoo him people look alike is this
guy out late last night probably got a
victim he's probably homeless but that
sure I knew the lady that played mag in
that show who's not the lead the lead is
Christine the other one is Meg Meg I
knew she used to sit in the Food
Emporium and drink clam chowder and
stare at the rain every day before she
had to walk into the theater she was a
cat-like woman very pensive startled
easily and you see these people they
just dedicate their lives to theater
like three people succeed my cousin my
third cousin is one of them
Bobby Lopez he wrote the music for
Avenue Q Book of Mormon frozen he got
winner Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony to to
leach is one thing he got twice he's won
two Emmys two Grammy to Oscar to Tony's
he's in the most elite but he deals like
Bob Michael Eisner who's the guy who
owns Bob Iger at Disney I don't know he
deals with those people personally he
said why do I have an ancient he said
what's think I don't know why I have W
babies like we're these people directly
he's the agent called him watch like
we're gonna get you more work he's more
work what there's no more work
dude frozen to like I'm doing like guys
got money he's like theater royalty his
best friends lin-manuel Miranda he came
to my grandma's you know once I'm like
hey come check out one of my comedy
shows he's like well your grandmother
was a good woman
that was it which is fair I get it it's
theater royalty but there's guys like
him his brother his little brother ended
up getting [ __ ] over he went into like
Nickelodeon or something and they stole
his idea or maybe was Adult Swim I don't
know one of those places maybe who's MTV
or Nickelodeon one of those things he
just went and pitched something then
three months later this tried to make it
I think it lawyers and everything yeah
do people don't care let's steal your
[ __ ] but most people in theater are
damned
so I think if you get out of dice jam
for four years you should have to at
least give it a shot you know it's a
tough profession man it's [ __ ] hard
as [ __ ] it's a very talented people is
very hard to bed idina menzel became
super famous she was that she was in
rant and then in wicked and then it
frozen she became super famous but dude
the amount of people that become super
famous for Broadway it's like three of
them it's very very hard and uh and I
don't care but I don't care it's that's
what it's supposed to be but it's what
it is to calling you believe in its
religion it's like everything we talked
about but those kids in Houston were
hilarious well actually use it as a
third largest time you shut the [ __ ] up
you clown pieces of fat one of the
fattest cities in America the only thing
they have the third-largest of is people
having coronaries at [ __ ] Arby's you
have the third-largest people in America
not the third largest art scene maybe
they view of the third but I think that
Bill Hicks joke you know when he goes
Iraq at the fourth largest in the world
but yeah after the first three armies a
real drop off after New York in LA but
is a real drop-off in art scenes Liz
Loza ass as the fourth largest art scene
in the country
try not to Liz I'm clapping with her
soon
dosha cat Eilish Liz Oh Dylan that's
much it what if I what if I somehow
became a recording artist you know what
what music would I have to do what kind
of music hmm hip-hop or something hey
that's for the blacks now oh really I
think they want I think that's what
makes it cool is that it's people black
people getting into a genre of music
they hadn't previously been into yeah I
picturing you with big black framed
glasses like FUBU full jumpsuit chains I
really picture you doing it I mean
there's so many people we know that
aren't funny at all that are very
successful as comic yeah most so it's
not layer majora it's not hard imagine a
big majority give a beat can you get a
beat up right now yeah let's see like a
beat where I could be a recording artist
I want to be like close Maloney though
I've been into rock star with my [ __ ]
I've been in a club with this ho she be
looking at me all night though I'll be
like where you going you ho she's like
I'm gonna go and get to blow I said
maybe we shouldn't do blow hold on yeah
this is we're tired you want to see how
easy it is to be recording artist I'll
give it to you right now
here we go I pull up in the belly she be
looking for a long time
r-really hard days but I gotta make the
song run this is ruining it little baby
not hold on I got a vibe with the beat
see me out of sunset all my boys and my
girls in the car everybody like this
isn't even fun yet and I'm like
society's collapsing cuz the corporate
state is owned and us we're livin
inverted totalitarianism my boss shall
the rolling corn that term he's dead now
Chris Hedges loves him where my HOS at
we might as well be foes now because we
can only come if it's violent we need a
lot of sexual violence our society is
built on war and murder of the innocent
the torture and rape of the innocent and
the murder of children because you know
that killing children and I'll be
chilling in my Rover American Empire is
over where my home who's that for you a
home for the corporate state I am spread
my [ __ ]
ExxonMobil [ __ ] me in my mouth yo
[Music]
sadi soda in my [ __ ] mouth bro put
your oil in my mouth and my ass
[Music]
I was to survive I mean I think that's
that that's now the critique of that
song would be that it's it's it's a
little too
it's very lyrical it's very lyrical and
but it's a vibe you know
yeah patreon.com slash the Tim Dylan
show please go sign up it's only $5 a
month
there's hundreds of hours of bonus
content on there it's a great way to
support the show also go to Tim Dylan
comedy comm he has a lot of shows coming
up New York New York
Caroline's March 12th through the 14th
Tim's going to be in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania at helium comedy club
March 19th through the 21st he's gonna
be in Des Moines at the funny bone in
Iowa March 26th through the 28th funny
bone in Manchester Connecticut April 3rd
through the 5th
Bloomington at the house of comedy April
9th through the 11th Albert
New York he's gonna be at the funny bone
April 17th to the 19th Dallas Texas
hyenas comedy club April 23rd 24th and
25th Phoenix Arizona is gonna be at the
house of comedy May 7th through the 9th
Columbus Ohio he's gonna be at the funny
bone May 21st through the 24th Omaha
Nebraska May 28th through the 30th at
the funny bone he's gonna be in San
Francisco over the summer June 4th
through the 6th at the punchline he's
gonna be in Springfield Missouri
June 12th through the 13th of the Blue
Room he's going back to Canada
June 18th through the 20th and Edmonton
at the comic strip and July 7th through
July 12th he's gonna be in New York at
levity live in West Nyack hope I'm
saying that right also remember that we
have merch we have a store on bonfire
I'll put a link in the description for
that two shirts with Tim dressed up as
Megan McCain on them we have life in the
big city shirts we have mugs we also
have a growing subreddit where you can
share clips from the show and talk to
other fans our slash Tim Dylan go check
that out follow Tim on Twitter at Tim
Jay Dylan follow him on Instagram at Tim
Jay Dylan as well and that's all for now
guys I hope you enjoyed all this bonus
content and we'll see you next week